if you look at what the chokehold is on
my business it's always the leader today
I want to talk about three ways that you
can move to make that consistent I'm a
humongous believer that ideas are and
that executions the game
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message learn to execute over to
you Tony Robbins also if you want to
know what Tony and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below the fact that human beings are
strongest drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions so if
you want to change your life my friends
you've got to change your physiology and
you got to change your focus
you know you get on an airplane what's
the first thing they say if we get into
trouble masks will come down oxygens
there and the first thing you got to do
is put it on your kid right no why
they literally tell you to put it on
yourself you selfish bastard what's the
deal here right but it's because we
don't take care of ourselves we can't
tear them so for leaders what I always
tell them is it's you first it starts
with you and it starts with your
psychology 80% of growing a business if
you look at what the choke hold is on
that business it's always the leader and
80% of that choke hold is the psychology
at 20% the mechanics I mean people in
this room know the mechanics and
strategy is beyond what anybody on earth
knows in their category so it's really
about you being in the state where you
execute it's like I always tell people
knowledge is not power it's total BS
knowledge is potential power execution
Trump's knowledge every day of the week
and some of my life is how do you get to
yourself to execute an execution comes
from learning to put yourself in that
right state of it it Tony's last
sentence was the most important
execution comes from learning to put
yourself in the right state every day
entrepreneurs we've all felt the right
state we all know what it feels like to
be on fire and motivated and bold you've
all had that in your life that's just
not consistent it's too fleeting you
might have attended a seminar or watch a
video write a book or have an inspired
conversation and that led you to feeling
like yes my dream is possible hanging
around this person makes me feel like
I'm unstoppable but if that person's out
there you fall back to your old habits
you fall back to your own patterns and
that is the story of too many
entrepreneurs where it's this constant
roller coaster bump and down and up and
down in terms of your motivation your
state your ability to be in the right
spot so they can go out and execute and
so today I want to talk about three ways
that you can move to make that
consistent so that you're not waking up
like an accident anymore and that every
day you set yourself up to be in the
right state to go off and achieve
and achieve and get closer to making
your mission actually at number one is
chart your start how you start your day
matters you need to chart it you need to
plan that you need to prepare for it it
starts by one reverse-engineering what
made you feel bold what gets you feeling
excited what gets you feeling motivated
and empowered you felt that you felt
that at some point in your life and so
what led you to feeling that and then
inject it into your morning routine
every single day it's one of the first
things that you do when you wake up stop
waking up like an accident stop waking
up checking your phone which is really
just other people's agenda for your time
when you load your phone and you check
your notifications and you're checking
your email you're responding to other
people's problems other people's
emergencies and now you just have to
make them your problems and your
emergencies instead of you setting up
the day with intention how you want to
start your day if you don't know what
that looks like the one word is a great
starting point if you understand what
your most important core value is then
you can build your day what does a
believe morning look like what is a
curiosity or inspire whatever your one
word is what does that morning routine
look like for you so that you are
feeling bold and unstoppable chart your
start plan for every single day number
two is play music the fastest way to
change your state that I know of is to
play music put on a song that makes you
want to move this is especially
important in the morning because when
you wake up you're tired you're groggy
you might be grumpy you might not have
had the best sleep you might have some
some kinks in your neck just got a crack
there you know you're feeling a little
out of shape you know you forgot what
happened yesterday and you're groggy to
start your day so put it on music
changes you putting on music there's no
right song but it's a song that makes
you move the song that makes you want to
dive makes you want to Bob your head
bounce up and down like whatever that
song is then that's what you want to
start your day with now also critical is
not having the exact same song every
single time because you'll get bored of
it and it won't mean as much to you
ongoing so what I do is I made a belief
playlist it's public you can check it
out
the songs are meaningful to me the songs
make me want to move in
bandannas and shake and so I listen to a
random song on that list at 1.25 speed I
think every song almost sounds better at
1.25 and I'll play that as part of my
morning routine every single day so if
you're ever feeling down low-energy sad
lethargic what most people do is
actually pick music to fit their mood if
you're feeling down you'll play this
really slow music and that just further
cements you feeling slowing down do the
opposite if you are feeling lethargic
put on the music that makes you come
alive and watch what happens in the next
couple of minutes and number three is
scheduled the unscheduled a lot of times
what makes people come alive and feel
motivated is some unscheduled things
some happenstance encounter again you're
watching some video reading a book or
you've met somebody listen some podcast
that just happened to follow and come
into your feet it just happened to show
up you go into your YouTube and this
video happens to show up and your
subscriptions or your recommended video
you can't rely on that so you want to
schedule the unscheduled you want to
find the consistent source so for
example if watching this channel helps
you if the videos are are net positive
and they're helping you you've got three
to choose from everyday subscribe to the
channel and get the email notification
so that all you have to do is look wake
up every morning and see the emails and
pick that one if you want to build
confidence that's why I built the 250
for confidence series where every
morning for the next 250 for mornings at
5:00 a.m. Eastern you are going to get a
video around confidence to help you
build unstoppable confidence but it's
not just me whatever if you hate my
content unsubscribe now and go find
somebody else
amazing whatever you're looking to try
to find the source a consistent source
so what I'm doing is injecting you with
different people's opinions as well as
my perspective a lot of people do that
there's a lot of YouTube channels where
there's different perspectives or
interviews of people coming on there's a
lot of podcasts you can listen to where
they're bringing different guests if one
of my guests one of the people that I
bring on one of people I profile means
way more to you than what I'm saying
great like go find their Channel go find
their podcast
go subscribe to them the goal here is to
move from randomly coming across some
video or having some chance encounter
and scheduling it in so that it becomes
part of your daily routine now I've got
a really special bonus skip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is the fastest way for you to get into a
state of wanting to go out and execute
let me know down the comments below
my assistants got a great thing now in
this once in every four months somebody
sends an email saying I've got a huge
startup that I want you to invest in but
you've got to sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says Q right and and the reason is
I'm a humongous believer that ideas are
and that executions the game right we've
all got ideas everybody's got ideas do
you mean ideas we all have here we can
probably sit here for the next two hours
draw them all out record them and
predict the next 78 great startups over
the next nine years and so I think the
thing that is another theme in
entrepreneurship is there is way too
much fodder brought to the idea Hoover
was magic cab three years earlier uber
is not an idea who ever existed it's
called magic cab but the guys that
executed sucked so they lost so I think
you know if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea
I'd like to suffocate it because I think
the actual situation is what you
actually do with it when if things go
wrong they always seem to happen at once
and they just compound on top of each
other and it's it's pretty easy
sometimes to to feel beaten when you're
faced with all those issues and all
those problems and they all hit you at
the same time but let me tell you that
that doesn't mean give up in fact it
means the opposite it means it's time
for you to fight harder to dig in means
it's time for you to go on the warpath
and that starts with one of the
fundamental laws of combat leadership
prioritize and execute what's the
biggest problem what's causing the most
stress family okay
sit them down explain where you are at
be blunt be upfront and then give them
the simple plan of how you're gonna get
things back on track don't sugarcoat it
you give it to them straight next you've
got some some late payments call those
creditors up explain to them what's
going on set up some kind of a low of a
minimum payment plan so you can start
making some progress and get them off
your back and then you got your job
[Music]
right you're falling behind at work okay
talk to your boss face it tell him that
you're gonna step up your game tell him
you're gonna be at work early you're
gonna be at work late you're gonna be at
work during lunch you're gonna be
wherever you need to be whenever he
needs you to be there tell him you're
gonna get after it and tell him that
you're a hundred percent committed to
supporting him and the company and the
mission and then you get started
raise your standard not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean if you want to learn more about
the advice Tony Robbins has for
entrepreneurs check out the master your
business video that we made on him the
link is right next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there there is
another level the only reason you keep
seeing there isn't as you feel so
exhausted about where you are